no matter what kind of stories you like
2018 was a pretty great year for movies
the best one served up scenes that took
over pop culture becoming instantly
iconic these are the moments from our
favorite movies of the year that we'll
still be talking about for years to come
the Mission Impossible series has become
a reliable adrenaline delivery system
and 2018 s fallout was no exception the
movie set pieces are all impressive but
the helicopter chase is the most
breathtaking with crews actually
learning to fly so he could perform the
scenes aerial maneuvers talk about
raising the bar not what I'm this close
a star is born is a classic showbiz
fable than one of 2018 s biggest hits
the scene in which Lady Gaga's alley
takes the stage with Bradley Cooper's
Jackson Maine for the first time was
instantly iconic the song shallow was a
chart-topping sensation standing alone
outside the context of the film but it
makes for an incredible dramatic moment
in the movie story - one that's
guaranteed to linger and viewers
memories for years to come gotta tell
you secret bohemian rhapsody' could have
ended with Freddie Mercury's death but
instead the story wrapped up on a high
point Queens legendary set at 1985 s
Live Aid many consider the performance
to be among the best Rock sets ever
which the biopic faithfully recreated
[Applause]
while only three songs made the movies
final cut the 20 minute six song set was
filmed in its entirety which fans will
get to see as an extra feature for the
movies home release a quiet place was
one of 2000 18s more unexpected hits a
nail-biting sci-fi thriller from
director John Krasinski nothing was a
better testament to his craftsmanship as
a filmmaker
than the harrowing childbirth sequence
in which Emma Leigh blunts character
goes into labor while alien beasts scour
the house around her
going into labor is a noisy experience
so watching blunts character try and get
through it without making a sound was
unbearably tense it's the best sequence
in the movie man one of the most
memorable scenes of the year
Marvel's Black Panther was one of 2018 s
biggest hits filled with memorable
locations and magnetic performances
everyone has their own favorite
character but deny Guerrero's Ocoee a
gets what's arguably the movie's most
crowd-pleasing sequence in the movies
Casino scene Guerrera steals the show
with an iconic moment that's both
hilarious and badass the scene starts
with the heroes undercover with a co a
donning a wig to better blend in she's
not a fan of it
aah squealing this will go quickly and I
can get this ridiculous thing off my
head
it looks nice just whip it back and
forth day but when the group's cover is
blown the warrior waste no time in
whipping off her wig and weaponizing it
it's not often that an action scene can
make such a clear statement about beauty
standards but black panther pulled it
off with style literally spider-man into
the spider verse one over audiences
everywhere bringing Marvel character
Miles Morales to the big screen for the
first time miles is a different kind of
Spider Man full of youthful exuberance
and insecurity which is debut plays up
in winning fashion and delight you know
I'm spider-man when miles gets his
powers he isn't even sure he's ready to
take up the mantle of spider-man
after he receives guidance from other
dimensions more experienced spider
people he learns the lesson that he'll
never be ready he just has to take a
leap of faith 2018 s most iconic scene
came at the climax of Avengers infinity
war man you already know the one we're
talking about the moment in which the
mad Titan Thanos accomplishes his goal
of snuffing out half of all life was one
of the most mind-blowing sequences the
superhero genre has ever seen instantly
becoming known simply as the snap
audiences watched in horror as Black
Panther dr. strange and more crumbled to
dust ending the movie on a devastating
cliffhanger I don't feel so good
you're alright I don't know I don't know
what's happening it's a sequence that
spawned a thousand memes endless
speculation and left fans wondering how
on earth they could wait a year to see
the story conclude the moment was a
gamble but it paid off big time with an
unforgettable scene that's unlike
anything that's come before it
comic-book movie or not audiences could
have revolted instead we're all waiting
on the edge of our seats to see how the
story will end check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite movies
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]